hotspot heim immer wieder haben pflege
und seniorenheime der senatsverwaltung
für gesundheit schwere krone ausbrüche
unter senioren und pflegekräften
gemeldet obwohl der schutz der
risikogruppen und vor allem der seniorin
seit monaten die höchste priorität für
politik haben sollte machen heimbewohner
nach angaben der verwaltung inzwischen
mehr als die hälfte aller corona
todesfälle aus wie konnte das passieren
in weit mehr als 1000 alten und
pflegeheimen bundesweit gibt es aktuell
corona fälle eine schocknachricht kam
vor einigen tagen aus dem pflegeheim
haus chiemsee bei rosenheim
dort waren alle 54 bewohner mit corona
infiziert wird im moment sind nur noch
zwei von 44 heimbewohnern infiziert bild
ist vor ort und sprach mit dem
heimleiter der macht den behörden ein
großes einen großen vorwurf wegen total
versorgen
bei der bewältigung der krise im
seniorenheim also die haben einfach
nicht entsprechend reagiert nachdem ich
die um hilfe gebeten habe
dieses besonders erstmal selber drum
kümmern
ob wir irgendwas machen zehn bewohner
mussten ins krankenhaus zwei männer im
alter von 97 und 80 jahren starben jetzt
ermittelt die rosenheimer
kriminalpolizei unter der fachleiter der
staatsanwaltschaft traunstein
ein massiver corona ausbruch ereignete
sich auch im kursana pflegeheim in
berlin lichtenberg
die feuerwehr evakuierte am 20 november
die einrichtung an der gensinger straße
dort waren zeitweise 47 bewohner
infiziert 15 starben
bereits im april hatte das würzburger
pflegeheim sankt nikolaus mehr als zwölf
tote gemeldet und die hälfte aller
bewohner des hauses hatten sich mit dem
korrekt 19 erreger infiziert wie viele
fälle muss es noch geben bis der schutz
verstärkt wird mache ich eigentlich sehr
traurig wenn ich daran denke was auf uns
zukommt weil unsere mitarbeiter müssen
gerade verwöhnt übernehmen die nicht
jede sind fakt ist unsere patienten und
bewohner werden ihre familien nicht
besuchen können
und das heißt für uns dass wir all diese
rollen erfüllen müssen das heißt wir
müssen tochter enkel nicht so und
weiteres sein dass sie träumen die nicht
unsere sind und ich denke das kann nicht
der richtige weg sein weil die bewohner
die alten menschen die deutschland nach
dem krieg aufgebaut haben die
wirtschaftskrise überstanden haben
haben wohl ein rechter auf selbst zu
entscheiden was sie wollen und so wie es
jetzt kommen wird wird es das traurigste
weihnachten was sicherlich unsere
monarchie jemals erlebt haben
auch wenn wir versuchen das beste daraus
zu machen das heißt für uns wir müssen
zu weihnachten mehr personal da stehen
um die tränen zu trocknen
so kann's nicht sein so kann es nicht
weitergehen weil man hat auch ein stück
weit die verantwortung an uns abgegeben
und hat gesagt mach mal
wir müssen zusehen wie klarkommen und
das kann mich das ziel sein das ist
traurig bauwirtschaft können sie uns
ganz konkret ihre forderung auch an die
spitzenpolitiker deutschlands einmal
nennen
es ist ja schön dass man jetzt danach
schreit dass die fachkräfte besser
bezahlt werden soll
das würden wir auch ganz gerne tun bin
wenn die tätigkeit wird unsere arbeiten
die wir verrichten besser honoriert
werden würden ich kann ja nicht mehr
ausgeben als
das funktioniert nicht an gehört zu
denen die insolvenz beantragen müssen
und ich denke der zug ist abgefahren man
hat die schläge in grund und boden
betreten
und jetzt möchte dass keiner mehr machen
und jetzt sollen wir zusehen wie wir dem
den karren aus dem dreck ziehen
es wird schwierig ich denke man sollte
einfach nicht unten geld allein ist es
nicht was die leute unsere akzeptiert
werden immer gesellschaft weil mitunter
wurden die menschen die pflege auf
andere tätigkeiten reduziert aber nicht
unsere hauptaufgabe sind hier geht es um
menschlichkeit und das sollte man im
vordergrund rücken bei dem thema fliegen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren